what's up um a bitters in game okay uh
so I have been thinking for the last
couple days or so about okay so AB
interesting game Oh forgive me my hat
where am I giving my head I guess it's
not a common explained video if I don't
have a hat on Avengers in game I have
been thinking for the last couple of
days yes I'm still getting over my cold
I'm still congested but like I don't
have a fever or anything like that so
hopefully I can get back to making
videos here in the next day or two um
well I guess I can now cuz I'm making
this one a bigger Zin game alright uh
Galactus okay I thought think about this
for the last couple days here's the
funny thing about this alright the
Marvel Cinematic Universe what made it
so cool what made the MCU so awesome is
that it was all based on this idea of
like small little Easter eggs right like
he watched every movie hoping you would
see a reference to like feature events
as they would unfold in the MCU right
like you watch one of the Iron Man
movies and you thought like the shield
of Captain America you soft like an Iron
Man one and then an Iron Man two like
Agent Coulson actually picks it up and
is like what are you doing with this you
know you you watch The Avengers movie
and then like you know
Iron Man makes reference to like Earth's
Mightiest Heroes you watch the Thor
movie and dr. Erik Selvig says well I
know a guy who's an expert in gamma
radiation I mean you know you you watch
these movies and you look for these
little these little tidbits and one of
the funny things about this is that
looking at the entirety of Avengers in
game a Disney owns a Fantastic Four in
the expo but and one of the big
questions people have been asking is
like how do they roll Galactus or like
Silver Surfer over into the MCU
and I think it'll be an easter egg
reference I think it'll be an offhand
remark by somebody like rocket with who
right because like rocket and nebula are
like really the only members of the
guardians who were basically left here
right like everybody else is essentially
gone and and with that I could see some
scenario for something going on with it
like formulating their plan and rockets
like huh well at least we don't have to
face Galactus and like that's it and
like that that's all you've just done
and like that would be enough because
it's just like did you just say Galactus
like you
dr. strange right the member of the
Bucks which when the doctor she fell
when when Baron Mordo is training
Stephen strange and he says this is the
staff of the Living Tribunal and for the
average moviegoer they were just like
okay but for color fans we were just
like watch did they just reference the
Living Tribunal like it's cool because
the staff of Living Tribunal actually
does exist in Marvel Comics
Lily tribunal doesn't really use it all
that often but like it does exist and so
it's it's it's coming okay that's cool
little stuff and to me like like
throwing them in that way would be
awesome because it isn't like we don't
need like a huge post-credit scene the
post-credits scenes are huge like that
they're really really cool because it
gives us like a visual but at the end of
the day the one big takeaway for the
post-credits scene is like this is a
thing that's coming like this is the
thing that's going to happen later on
down what like Howard the Duck like
Howard the Duck exists in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now because he wasn't
of course [ __ ] scene and it's it's
it's a cool thing to see Marlee it's a
cool little thing to have and so to me
like if you were if they were gonna
reference your Galactus in the Silver
Surfer throw them in there now if they
wanted to do a post-credits scene they
could and here's here's here's a cool
bit about it is a lot of people sort of
have a tendency to ask this question
right because people want order people
want structure when it comes to like
comment with movies and and there's you
know people would look at that they
would say well if Galactus exists then
how come he's never been referenced
before well the answer is because
there's been a bit of reason to and the
universe is a big place
and that's that's the cool thing about
it is literally like if you look at the
entirety the Marvel Cinematic Universe
what do we have in relation to like the
greater universe as a whole right like
we've basically got the the scrolls who
exist out there you know basically on
well I students scroll up still exist
you've got you've got the Kree who
exists on Halla you have well the reason
why I say I assume scroll of still
exists is because in the comics coatt
just destroyed the Galactus basically
like consume the world and then consume
scroll us and then that led him to
Secret Invasion but um
nope well it was a combination with
things that was the big thing that led
into Secret Invasion anyway like like
this the Kree exists on hala out there
somewhere uh if they if you know with
flight Disney owning the x-men now that
means the Shiar Empire exists out there
you know so out there in
you know the universe somewhere but all
we've really seen is like this the Milky
Way galaxy and like that's it but like
all the other galaxies that are out
there all the other places that are out
there like if all we've seen is a Milky
Way galaxy which is like one
infinitesimally small fraction of like
the universe's size it makes sense that
Galactus is out there somewhere just
like consuming worlds right because in
Marvel Comics like not everything takes
place in the Milky Way galaxy like 90%
of the stuff that takes place in space
is way outside the Milky Way galaxy it's
way out in like other parts of the
universe and other part of other
galaxies that exist out there and things
like that as well it is kind of a kind
of a cool reference because you could do
that in a post-credits scene right like
half the life of the universe vanishes
and and you almost get this sort of star
wars feeling right work at work a lot
this is like you know like I sense ain't
like a fundamental change in the
universe somebody along those lines you
know and then like he continues on
feeding whatever it is and the Silver
Surfer shows up and says hey like we
figured out what the source of you know
half the life of the universe vanishing
it's coming from and like it happened on
earth and so then like it draws Galactus
attention to earth which brings Galactus
in as a possible villain there's a lot
different ways that you could do that
but in reality I think they're just
having Galactus in the in the MCU just
referencing him as an offhand remark is
awesome you know because it's it because
what it could basically do is say hey
like at least we're not facing Galactus
and just like with a statement like that
it immediately introduces Galactus in
the MCU and it shows Galactus as being
that powerful right like just that
capable now again like there are people
who will be like well Galactus couldn't
defeat them else with the Infinity
Gauntlet and they're right I mean that's
that's a true statement but what it does
is it shines Galactus in a new light and
say hey they had us with the Infinity
Gauntlet is not the most powerful being
out there because he's not I mean like
tennis with the Infinity Gauntlet is
really powerful but like there's like
five or six people and Marvel Comics who
like whose power level transcends the
universe and expands into the multiverse
and I'm not even talking about like
cosmic beings right like I'm not even
talking about like the Phoenix force or
like though the Living Tribunal or the
one above all or like Protege or anybody
like that like I'm talking about
characters like the molecule man Owen
Reese the Beyonder or like - beyonders
those other ones I mean like like all
those characters like Mad Jim Jasper's
people's whose power is like so extreme
that it's a legitimate threats like the
multiverse as a whole
like the omniversal development court
the ability just like destroy entire
universes things like that like oblivion
being powerful enough to like cuz
oblivion is crazy like here's the here's
the thing here is the thing oblivion is
crazy when it comes to Marvel comics
because oblivion is basically the
representation of non-existence right
like the time that so like when that
when the multiverse ends well you got a
multiverse here and then you've got a
multiverse here this in-between where my
phases is the time it takes for the new
multiverse to form oblivion represents
that he represents the existence of
nothing so basically like he's as
powerful if he as he wants to be like
he's infinitely powerful shy of like the
one above all but like I mean you're
talking about beings like the chaos king
like crazy crazy powerful entities only
the chaos king resonates into the
multiverse but nonetheless you're
talking about some exceedingly powerful
beings out there and so while Thanos is
really really powerful with the with the
the Infinity Gauntlet he's not the end
of all things and so it's kind of cool
because you know having like referencing
Galactus in that way works perfectly and
the same thing with like with with the
Silver Surfer now like again a
post-credits scene I think it'd be more
beneficial and in reality I think we'll
see one I think we'll see a post-credits
scene because I feel like the the merger
between Disney and Fox went through
early enough to where a post-credits
scene can be made pretty quickly you
know kind of thrown out there relatively
fast and still still make it out in time
for like the release of the movie right
it really kind of comes down to the time
it took between the the Disney deal
closing and the time that's like the
movie gets to the theaters right because
like when the theaters get the film they
get it all they get everything from like
the opening credits all the way to the
very end which is like the post credits
scene so if not enough time passed
that's fun and again we probably
wouldn't see like reshoots or anything
but again that's just you know it's all
kind of intriguing because I have to
believe that while we as the general
public saw that like the deal went
through on this particular date
he was guaranteed long before that
anybody who told you that like if
they're like there was no way Disney was
gonna buy Fox did like Comcast or
somebody was gonna get instead they were
they were full of hoo-ha juice
anybody who has any measure of common
sense whatsoever new Disney was gonna
get Fox instead there was no denying
that like it was guaranteed like it was
an absolute fact it was just a matter of
when it would happen but nonetheless you
know I'm kind of like
here um it makes for some cool stuff
because then like with with with you
getting go actress then you have to
start thinking about like dr. doom
and you have to start thinking about
like Reed Richards and and those
characters honestly I haven't really
come up with a with a tangible theory on
how dr. doom could be could like be
thrown into the MCU there's ways to do
it you know but I can't really think I
mean I can't really think of a way to
make it work I mean I guess you could
have just saying he's always been there
but nobody ever went to Liberia because
Olivia is a black hole right like nobody
gets in nobody gets out because dr. doom
keeps on a very very very tight leash
and you could have that and like
spider-man far from home just have some
fun where Peter Parker's like you know
sitting in some place where the rest of
us classmates and there's like a news
clip that comes on you know and it's
like and in other news today you know
Doctor Doom has open the doors of
Latveria to anybody looking to you know
or whatever any number of things but
just like reference it in some offhand a
news clip there's ways to make it work
but I don't know either way I will say
that like I think we will see a
reference or even like a post credit
scene with Galactus and the Silver
Surfer and the individuals in-game right
I mean the only way I think we wouldn't
do that is if again you know like Disney
decided to play it safe and was like
well during like all the shoots and
everything we never made any reference
to him because we didn't really know if
the deal was gonna go through and then
we kind of knew it was you know whatever
the case whatever the case may have been
but that's that's how do we run into a
weird situation is because you know when
it comes to the x-men and when it comes
to the Fantastic Four there is a little
bit of like charting water in terms of
like how to get them in there in a way
that makes it tangible and makes it
realistic and even for a couple of movie
doesn't really stretches though to
stretch the lines of credulity right the
limits of credulity that it's still kind
of like okay this is possible like
that's kind of really need but but still
you know I think they Galactus out there
would be cool because having a being
that travels around and consumes worlds
would be a huge change for the MCU
because what it does is it starts to
like kind of expand the realm of threats
that are out there you know and that's
kind of a cool thing because then if the
story comes along and it says well the
Silver Surfer was made a herald of the
like just by this way then people start
asking the question but what would
happen what would happen if like the
lottery showed up on earth and made like
Iron Man his Herald or if he made Thor
his Herald which he's done or if he made
the Incredible Hulk is her what she did
in an alternate reality you know what if
he showed up any and he took like
spider-man
and make spider-man is Harold there's a
lot of different questions people could
ask about that and literally like
there's what there's all kinds of
possibilities to explore so I don't know
I mean that this problem is kind of
spitballing just kind of throwing ideas
out there but I love the idea I mean let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments like do you guys think that we
will see a reference to the live just
and the Silver Surfer in Avengers in
game or do you guys think that we will
not see anything in relation to the
x-men fan has like four or none of that
stuff because we know the expert on the
Fantastic Four the Russo brothers on
finding them of seven like they're not
coming immediately right like they're
not gonna be like phase four right it's
not gonna be like we get like Black
Panthers who and like spider-man home or
spy land far from home and then like
whatever other movie we get to conclude
phase four and then we go and conclude
phase three then we go on to phase four
we get Black Widow and then like x-men
like it's not gonna happen that way
finally there's a path Besson that's not
gonna happen you know they're like it'll
be a while before we see them introduced
into the MCU supposedly they're they
want to build up to like a vineyard vs.
x-men which okay I want to talk about
that which I'm kind of excited about the
idea of Avengers vs. x-men in the MCU
seems pretty legit like it seems pretty
solid what talking more about this in
like a different video just because of
so damn Clickbank Reilly Avengers
in-game Avengers vs. x-men like it
sounds super click thing but nonetheless
like I think it'd be I think we pretty
solid you know to see like to see I
leave pretty solid to see the whole
thing see the whole thing unfold but
unless you know focusing on Galactus and
Silver Surfer
I like the idea you know I like the idea
of having some kind of some kind of
reference in there this sort of provides
a scope a frame of reference for
Galactus they're like hey Thanos was
really popular really powerful with the
Infinity Gauntlet
but he ain't the only dog barking in
this finally he's like he's on he's not
the only dog on this block that they can
take a chunk at he's like there's some
pretty heavy hitters out there and like
you guys as heroes on earth have no clue
what's out there you guys have no clue
what goes on in the universe but just
wait and and eventually we as the viewer
will see it as time as time unfolds but
nonetheless um without being said guys
we're gonna breed this video to an end
let me tell you guys think I'm really
kind of picking your brains here you
know what do you guys think about the
whole Galactus Silver Surfer thing do
you think we'll see it you know what was
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comics explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the rob
Court if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
[Music]